well so let me let me pull up this next
story from the daily mail it's actually
just a meme elon musk hints he's shifted
to the right over the last 14 years no
no daily mail that is not what he's
saying it's hilarious as liberals
morphed into woke progressives he is not
saying he shifted to the right he's
quite literally saying he has not moved
at all in this image i believe it's a
meme from colin wright that's correct
yeah that's congratulations colleen very
cool uh he posted him with me and now a
meme of you it is just a win winning
week for us in 2008 you can see there's
the right-wing conservatives the
left-wing liberals and there's me left
of center and it says my fellow liberal
in 2012 the left started moving way
further left and now me was closer to
center because left and right were
spreading further apart by 2021
me the character in the comic has stayed
in the exact same place
but the left has gone so far left
that me is now closer to conservative
and you know what's funny elon musk elon
musk elon musk posted that i always mix
the next word up in elon musk elon musk
posted that and i said that perfectly
explains this show and me
we are not conservatives we have always
been well sheamus is conservative i'm
sure conservative definitely but i mean
like here like me personally and you
know the stuff i've been working on you
know i got started covering news and
media with occupy wall street i was i
was politically active writing punk
music and protesting war with all these
liberals voting for obama in 2008
and then
throughout the next you know bernie
sanders
he was he was opposed to immigration he
said open borders was a koch brothers
proposal he wanted to help the working
class said gun rights was an urban
versus rural issue and i'm like i like i
like this guy he's been consistent he's
standing up for these things i can
respect that and then bernie decided to
run along with the left
as did so many other personalities and
they sacrificed any sense of principle
and conviction for tribe
so here i am standing in the same place
and now they're like your right wing and
i'm like that's exactly my point
so you've got this memes posted and this
dude this guy max
verified twitter user posts it and says
the right literally tried to overthrow
the government the left nominated joe
biden and i'm like you're proving the
point
nearly every single right-wing person
condemned what happened correct on
january 6 said it was wrong some of
those prominent right-wing individuals
all said the violence was a big mistake
and they shouldn't have done it
you didn't just elect joe biden you are
pushing for
strange
secret sexual conversations among
children
you have now uh there there's outright
leftist policy like uh bernie sanders
wants 20 of corporations to be owned by
the workers
and you have my friends the green new
deal this is what i referenced i when if
you look at my my videos
it was back in 2018 i think
when aoc was talking about the green new
deal i said fantastic i love the idea
the government should be taking this tax
money and investing in wind farms you
know solar energy roads bridges let's
get the infrastructure built back up
because these bridges are crumbling we
can't live this way
aoc is finally about to announce the
green new deal and i'm like let's see it
and she goes free healthcare for black
people and i'm like okay wait hold on
all right you want to have a
conversation about racial issues and
and you know
they say people of color i'm down but
what does this have to do with wind
farms so here i am actually looking at
environmental policy instead what do we
get critical race theory
so
i'm not taking away sheamus well no i
mean this is something we see the left
doing constantly you guys all know my
theory uh leftism is just a word that we
give to social decay things change very
quickly when they're breaking down so
you demolish a building it falls a lot
more quickly
than it took to put the thing together
in the first place of course there are a
lot of people who are considered to be
on the left who are now looked at as
right-wing figures and not only that but
far-right figures now i'm only 27 years
old and yet i am old enough to remember
when you had to be conservative in order
to be considered far-right now you can
be a pretty middle-of-the-road moderate
type or even a soft liberal and be
considered far-right i can straight up
be like well i for one think we need a
progressive tax and universal basic
health care and they're like he's far
right he's far right well it's just a
pejorative now it's just a label like
anything else to put you down call you a
racist far right and then people
hope after the first label you don't
read about what you're actually saying i
like that alt-right because like yeah
what is that is that up it's like it's
actually down because it's the new nazi
you only have one right was the was the
kind of during during trump was turn it
off
and the the the alt-right had a lot in
common with the woke left in terms of
their racial ideology so racism in fact
that's actually how the alt-right
explained it in many circumstances that
it was actually expressed to me
that the alt-right is basically black
lives matter for white people yeah yeah
that white community movement
is exactly no no no no white purity
that's a bit much know what they were
pride no no white pride what they were
literally saying it's okay to be white
you can you can accuse them of secretly
believing whatever they want what many
of these guys were publicly saying was
white rights right they were like all
we're trying to do is make sure that you
know we have equal rights
and look you can call them liars but
that's what they were publicly stating i
had a lot of my i had to moderate minds
i'd see a lot of white purity stuff that
was really annoying that's totally
different it was i mean that's why
yeah but that's i think where the
alt-right came from is they thought that
that was this dangerous racist white
racist movement but this this black
lives matter is very similar i'm not
gonna say the exact same thing but
nothing like a race the general idea
which allowed the uh like literal
neo-nazis to recruit was that they were
going to young white men who were
frustrated for a variety of reasons
couldn't find work and they were saying
hey you see all those memes
all those news stories about how white
people are bad and evil doesn't that
frustrate you and make you angry
join us and they would say okay my
grievance has now been addressed yeah
it'd be a normal guy would be like okay
fine and then he'd make a post that
would say it's okay to be white and
you'd be like and then they'd be like oh
he's he's indicating racism this is a
racist movement you know and then the
left it's there's this kind of push on
both sides and then you know you make
this symbol this firefighter made and
now he's a white national and there was
this whole media circus behind all of it
that took you know i'm sure there were
plenty of you know
white supremacist fringes in that
movement but the vast majority of them
were probably just guys saying i'm a
straight white guy
what's wrong with me
and then you get this pushback from the
left saying you're this that the other
thing and you make them more extreme
because you're continually trying to
one-up each other yeah i mean when you
look at how hard the left has to reach
and grasp its draws in order to conjure
up any kind of narrative of america
being a white supremacist country
basically all the hate crime narratives
we hear end up being completely false
upon further investigation they don't
hold up to the slightest scrutiny
every single time they accuse someone of
being racism it's because they dog
whistled a dog whistle which was also a
dog whistle that could possibly have
some racist meaning behind that only
they could hear and somehow only
left-wing people but also you would hear
things like you know asian hate asian
hate asian hate and then you would you
know look further and it was a black guy
with an asian girl black guy black and
then you watched in the media that the
race which was just part of as being an
editor you would ask their age and
normally their race normally just
started to vanish so if it was a group
of five black kids it would just save
five people if it was five white men
doing something to somebody else you'd
see something especially with a white
guy going after an asian they would
always show that it was a white guy yeah
and then i found out that it was a lot
of fun
even more in cities so i'm not sure if
you all remember a couple of years ago
there were there was a group of
black young adults who kidnapped a white
young adult with autism and tortured him
for days and it was a consistent trend
that in media
they were referred to as kids and he was
referred to as a man right were they
even though they were all over the age
of 18. oh that's weird yep because and
it's the same thing whenever you have
any kind of racial narrative if the
white person is the victim and they're
attacked by another minority group or a
minority group um then the race is left
out of it but
if there's a minority being attacked by
a white person of course the racial
identity is front and center ethnic
identity it's front and center in the
report it feels like there's a very
small minority of vocal racists that
were like white supremacist racists that
use social media to amplify it and then
there's a very small minority of black
supremacists these people that are like
trying to run the black racist movement
and we're caught in the middle most
people are and they're like what in the
hell but then it starts to seep into the
politics and then you're like oh god we
gotta let me take control of our
government i wanna pull this tweet from
nate silver he says folks it's not that
hard the left has moved to the left in
the u.s and the right has moved to the
right what that's not true no pew
research actually tracked and um i think
they did this based on the language used
by both parties yes
it is plain to see
the right has moved a little bit to the
right okay fine fair point the left has
gone completely off the rails
so when from where i'm standing i can't
even see where the left is i'm like what
are they doing i look up to my right and
i'm like oh there's a guy who doesn't
believe in gay marriage i'm like but but
that's recognizable to me i disagree but
i've seen that before the difference as
a gay man let me just tell you that
the the difference was
in the past if you weren't against gay
marriage that was fine
you know that was one thing now the left
has to destroy you
for that view that's how so the old left
would just be like you know give them a
chance it's not going to change your
life and now they're finding out where
you work so they can tell your bloss
your homophobe that's the from a gay
man's point of view who looks at all
this insanity and sees that i've seen
that change where you could just
disagree like say i don't think that i
think it's a traditional thing that you
know man and a woman go have your civil
unions
fine
the liberal in the audience would be
just like oh you know you should really
think that over now the liberal in the
audience gets on twitter tells them who
you are and has you fired and that's
how far the left have gone with these
types of and you can pick any topic and
they'll do the same thing
i do believe that the right has gone
further right it's just been banned off
of social media because i i had to
administer these people on mines like i
saw them exodus from twitter youtube and
facebook and like they were very extreme
yeah i think what's happened is when i
think i hate to keep saying trump all
the time but when he came along
an industry popped up where you had this
disinformation in fact for some reason
we had social media for years that
didn't need fact checkers cnn was from
the 80s and didn't have a
front focal fact checker that needed to
come out every 10 minutes dale and tell
you what he was right that's what the
journalist was supposed to do and i
think what happened over the years was
that the highlighting of these terrible
things um
were amplified and so an event occurred
there was six people now there's white
nationalism and then trump must like
that and then all the just like
if you're a conservative today then you
agreed that people should burn down the
capital i mean that's where we are in in
your discord these days if you're
conservative or you voted for trump then
you think that the riots were fine and i
wanna i wanna i wanna point out another
big issue in all of this too and i have
this pew research democrats and
republicans more ideologically divided
than in the past and we can see 9404
2014
this is the chart that's often cited by
many people there's another one that
updates it and it shows a later year i
think 2018.
you can see in this chart the very least
that in the 90s democrats and
republicans overlapped greatly in 2004
they did quite a bit republicans had a
bit more
by 2014 the democrats have moved much
further left and the republicans have
moved to the right you can see by
looking down here at the bottom right
now the democrats jumped i think like
three or four points to the left and the
republicans have moved like one or two
here's the fascinating thing nate silver
has another bit of data from pew
research saying the exact opposite this
killed me this shows the democrats
staying static and the republicans going
to the far right but nate silver also
said hillary was going to win but these
are these are both from pew research
right so what will happen is nate silver
chooses this and says oh see the
republicans went far right and then what
did we just cite a moment ago i cited
the data saying the opposite so i just i
throw this in the garbage i'll tell you
this the only real change i've had in my
politics is gun rights
i used to be kind of middle of the road
like maybe there could be some gun
control and now i'm like no gun control
everybody gets 50 bmgs
everything else is basically the same
mine's social medicine i used to be all
about it but now i see these people that
just eat crappy food and refuse to stop
i'm not going to pay for them right yeah
i
mean
no one with any sense can take a chart
like that seriously it's just something
that left-wing people believe in because
they buy into all the hate hoaxes they
hear from the media and they genuinely
believe that america has become a
fascist country because donald trump was
elected fairly in 2016. we did a video
about this for freedom tunes where we
debunked a similar analysis that carl
carlos mazza was using and so we sort of
went through and pulled it apart but
in order to get figures like this
the one that we debunked specifically
which i'm sure uses a similar
methodology basically put obama and
harry truman on the same level with
respect to how far to the left they were
anyone who knows anything about history
or either of those men will tell you
that that's absolutely ridiculous and
you mentioned earlier that obama is on
the right technically speaking or
according to the analysis you brought up
earlier he was the most far-left
president we had ever had up until the
point when he was elected he campaigned
on universal health care not a dramatic
and complete overhaul of our health care
system to the left that was substantial
and
as a senator in illinois he voted
against the born alive act which would
prevent you from being able to kill the
child after they were born if the
abortion failed let's let's let me
address this tweet from sawyer hackett
who responded nate silver sawyer is a
blue check coast of our america podcast
and he says
the left healthcare should be free i
think the right washington is run by a
cabal of child trafficking pedos and we
should violently overthrow
both sides am i right
well let's break this down
the left is some people who think
healthcare should be free but would that
include me
well i just said i think we should have
universal basic health care i say that
all the time no it doesn't include me i
also don't think washington is run by a
cabal of child trafficking you know
whatever i think that's just corrupt
people doing corrupt things i do think
people like epstein have a strange
amount of influence among powerful
global elites but that's a fact
so what is he really referring to what
they're doing is either they're
completely blind or they lie as a means
to an end
when they say by any means necessary
when they smash windows when they kill
when they lie cheat and steal and then
they look at a group of you know 800 or
so people who violently ride it at the
capitol and we sit here and say that was
wrong they shouldn't have done that
those who are violent will go to prison
they ignore that outright
when they lie and make up things about
the parental rights and education bill
they this is the game they play
now there are people on the right who
play similar game for sure but at look
i'm approaching this from i read
different news sources i use ground.news
and look at the bias and ownership of
these news outlets they can show you if
it's conglomerate private interest they
can tell you if it's left-leaning or
right-leaning and what i find is that on
the right
for whatever reason someone like ben
shapiro one of the most prominent
conservative personalities whether or
not people like him he's very famous
with one of the biggest podcasts in the
country nate the world
and he is a very moderate conservative
guy he's not far right he's got your
traditional conservative positions and
he bases his assessments on fact
on the left you have people like rachel
maddow who for years said insane things
about russia jenk yeuger who just called
for intervention in ukraine because he
thinks russians are staging waging this
war because they want to kill gay people
you have people like joy reid
who didn't she claim that she was
attacked yes but did they debunk that no
she wasn't hacked she had written all
these anti-gay homophobic things and
then you know she was going to get
investigated and then that vanished and
lies oh yeah let me let me go through
shall we go through the lies again i
mean do we really have to keep doing
this list we only have like an
the daily beast has now been rated as
caution fake news i'm adding the fake
news but caution you know very big
violation of journalistic ethics by
newsguard and it's primarily because
everything they report on cal right now
is wrong and they refuse to correct it
that's the left that is the
establishment and it is the people who
are like you know you've got these
leftist personalities who are like well
i don't like the democrats i'm on the
left but you all should vote for joe
biden
joe biden is a corrupt authoritarian and
these people supported him so spare me
at the very least i can explain donald
trump he's a bull rampaging through the
ivory tower don't like him and the
things he does that's fine he was a bull
rampaging through the ivory tower i
could i could accept that but i like
some of his policies they play this game
where they they're obtuse on purpose or
they're genuinely just broken people
well they also in the media they'll
they'll just
leave facts out and they do look the
covington kids you can go down the list
of things and if you own the shop like
they do they're not going to report it
and they've they've lived through this
whole existence where they're not used
to being called out and they you know
roger hale said to me once about you
know and he's famously said to it in in
public that you know there's 30 liberal
sites and
organizations on the left and there's
just us and they can't they lose their
mind over us and it's because
they call fox like the canary in the
coal mine so
you notice if you've watched fox and god
only knows i lived my life doing this
for a living which was
they've been talking about the border
for months and months and months and now
all of a sudden you start to see this
creep into cnn and title 42 and what are
we gonna do and you're like if you've
been watching fox you've heard about it
since you know
last year when they were coming across
the border so the media has famously
when it comes to writing about the left
or the right they will picking it it's
the gay you know the gay don't say gay
bill you know nothing in the bill said
gay and yet it's if you looked at the
headlines they just copied and pasted
off they went
just because you know i've worked in
newsrooms it's a bunch of 20 year old
people afraid to not go on a date and
it's a bunch of old editors who are
afraid to get yelled at on twitter or
afraid to not go on a date
afraid to afraid that they won't you
know if you have a bunch i've seen it in
conservative new rooms in dc where you
still have young people who are quote
unquote conservatives but they are very
in tune to what people are saying to
them about them on twitter because they
have to live in this liberal city and so
it affects you know it affects
you know what we're seeing with
everything is fierce ability to come
back at people like you know you do and
other people they you know you will say
what you mean and not worry about it
whereas you have so many people who are
terrified because they see what happens
to people they get canceled i mean you
know this libs of tit talk comes out
there and just basically just rewrites
what people not saying you didn't change
the video yeah it's like hillary's
emails nothing of those emails were made
up that's what they said you know let
people read them and all these people
are crazy but the libs of tick tock was
a perfect example she has a million
followers now because of these people
but they're so threatened by just but
all it did was bring and take the filter
out of the media because you think the
media is going to go look at what people
are saying about kids being taught this
or that in school because those are the
facts take a look at this story from
2019
when did barack obama become a
republican oh boy i don't know how about
this one from the washington post
november 22 2019 barack obama
conservative
yeah so when they're like the right has
moved to the right and also barack obama
who's in favor of universal health care
is a conservative and republican y'all
have lost the plot i'm sorry there's not
even a point to reading through this
stuff at this point well here's the
thing barack obama is not to the left as
the niche far left ideology that like
some 16 year old on twitter is posting
about therefore he's on the right
right
i'm all right i can't contribute because
i don't know what the right and the left
are anymore donald trump was a liberal
guy that ran for the republican party
tribe it's tried i guess so and
depending on where you're standing
i think it's a community i think people
but trump trump was the guy i said this
before when you were the
boomer me or
gen x yelling at the tv he yelled back
for years they would scream at the tv
about immigration or something and for
once a politician actually yelled back
at them and they heard them like
somebody heard me yelling and they went
out in droves i friends up in
massachusetts who were staunch liberals
who were like you know what i'm going to
vote for him because i've seen hillary
and i don't want that but he speaks to
me now you know ten years ago as a
conservative you know you'd be thrown
out if you even a hint that you cheated
on your wife
and now that's fine because
people were so sick of being talked down
to
that you know the flyover states and
this and that that he he hit a nerve in
people and everyone you know the people
who voted for him remember him in the
80s they weren't you know they remember
ivanka do you remember that whole show
of a mess that took place in his life
they knew it wasn't going to be pretty
but they wanted to blow that city up and
you know it blew up the media him
everyone around him and you know it
changed america forever yeah you
mentioned some of the misdeeds in
trump's personal life the left spent
years telling us that we shouldn't care
how a person conducts themselves in
their private life what we should care
about are the policies policies they
support as if a political leader is just
a set of policies and not a person who
has to make moral decisions by the
people that they're committed to and
then trump comes along and he absolutely
did not follow the rules that i
as a christian and many conservatives
would say that a political leader should
but he didn't hate us he didn't
absolutely detest us like virtually
every other political leader of my
lifetime has and so conservatives said
you know what we'll take this guy and
the left went but don't you care about
his personal life didn't didn't he call
rosie o'donnell a fat pig
and everyone was laughing and screaming
and sharing and yeah i mean you know he
he said things that a lot of people
thought and it was people you know he
you're right he he didn't he's a
billionaire who should look down from
his tower but for whatever reason if you
talk to these people especially people
at the i went some of these these events
with him
and it was like a god showed up because
it it's a lot of people who spent a lot
of years
caring about the country and watching it
tick away and somebody's now he was
flawed and you can say what you want
about him but his heart was at least in
the right place from their point of view
and you know we need the americans want
to be involved in the political
processes they should be in the
president's their our representatives so
for a president to respond to you and
allow themselves to be changed by your
opinions that's the point well i think
he embodied that and that's why a lot of
people really like donald trump
i also i also want to mention this on
the point of his personal life and his
private life it's not exist it's not as
if we just had this abundance of very
well conducted moral people to choose
from first president of the united
states like you didn't have the most
moral person who had ever lived running
next to donald trump hillary's trump
versus hillary clinton i see that in the
republican primaries it was like trump
first a bunch of swamp creatures
right
for the most part not all of them but i
when i saw hillary in 2016 i just
laughed i was like you think i'm gonna
vote for that you're insane
this lady was like
warmonger of war mongers
but she but the first female president
oh and you know what she doesn't believe
all women if you're not monica lewinsky
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there is a massive library
to check out so again go to timcast.com
or tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
we'll see you all there
you